years ago when i was doing one tree hill  my character was becoming a fashion  designer so i was like coming to fashion  week here and meeting with all these  people and learning about how they do  what they do for research  and i went to this dinner  and rihanna comes to this dinner and we  sit next to each other and she's like  your show's cool we're chatting i'm  dying she gives me her phone number  which i input in my blackberry at the  time  and i never texted her and then that  photo you showed i saw her at an event  years later and she was like how have  you been i never heard from you and i  was like oh my god i ghosted rihanna  like  what is wrong with me but i just i'm  like what do i what am i gonna text her  like hey girl what i don't know how to  talk to her